oublier
et il vient de la famille ou est un parent
puis une fois qu'elle était là
Il doit aussi voir un autre patient qui
a causé la mort puis le tribunal
terminé et les conditions que le
nous avons dû en terminant ici payer votre
phrase à l'intérieur de l'hôpital
[Musique]
bon
et
Yo
regarde comment on traite
en juif complet
Vous ne savez pas à quelles heures il peut s'agir d'un
patiente par derrière
partie peut un coup
ici des collègues de la sécurité nous ont tués
certains patients agressifs se sont déchiquetés
le visage et c'était comme ça le pauvre
parents pour veiller sur sa mort et personne
n'a pas répondu de cela ni du ministère de ses
l'organisme a pris la responsabilité de
ce
[Musique]
plus loin
Je pense que nous ferions ces salles de bain que nous sommes
ils n'ont pas de couronne ils n'ont pas de lumière regarde non
ils en ont desservent les salles de bains
il n'y a pas d'eau donc avec des chalets un avec
la vocation on ne travaille pas ne nous atteint pas
vouloir ne nous vient pas on est là pour
isme pour répondre aux besoins de
espace
[Musique]
soi-disant soi-disant et quelle farine d'avoine
vous pouvez voir que c'est une eau
Sans lait, sans rien, regardez, c'est de l'eau pure.
le patient ne mange rien d'autre ne boit plus
rien ne prends rien d'autre jusqu'à demain à
8 heures du matin que ce qu'ils vont vous donner
C'est un autre verre de ce même qu'avant
un seul arepa
[Musique]
mais non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]